So we demonstrated how you can condition a fear response with a little Albert
study. But there are some fear responses that can be conditioned after a single
pairing. Phobias can be conditioned after a single pairing. Say you were stung
by a bee once and you were allergic, so every time you saw a bee you were
scared of it. Or if you had a near drowning experience when swimming, you might
always be scared of the water after that. But we're going to talk about phobias
more later in the course when we talk about psychological disorders. But there
is one thing I want to talk about here. Condition taste aversion. That can
happen after just a single pairing. Let me go grab Susan so I can demonstrate
this to you guys.